Shazaam is officially out in theaters
and if you have watched it and are
wondering what that post credit scene is
all about you've come to the right video
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
if you are trying to avoid all possible
spoilers about Shazam and it's post
credits scene this is your official
spoiler alert
in Shazam we saw Billy Batson or Shazam
and his family defeat dr. sivana and the
seven deadly sins but of course it was
not the end for dr. sivana
he's one of Shazam's main villains so
they're not getting rid of him that
easily so of course at the end of the
movie he is taken into custody for
trying to kill a bunch of kids with
demons that came out of his eye so in
the post-credits scene we see dr. sivana
in a padded cell he has clearly gone
crazy he has lost all of the power that
the seven deadly sins gave him and he is
trying to get it back we see him drawing
all over the walls the symbols that
unlock the doorway to the rock of
eternity clearly trying to get a door to
open to send him back after yelling out
of frustration that the symbols are not
opening the doorway he hears a voice and
the voice says you assume there is only
one way to gain magic
oh no no there are more ways than a mind
can imagine it then zooms in on a little
tiny caterpillar with a speak box on it
and then the caterpillar says oh what
fun we're going to have together
the seven realms are about to be ours
and this little tiny caterpillar is the
one and only mr. mind an alien from
space that wants to take over the world
we saw this same caterpillar in the
beginning but it seems like he escaped
when dr. sivana defeated the wizard
because when Billy Batson goes back we
see that the caterpillar has in fact
escaped
mr. mind is most commonly known for
creating the monster Society of evil and
him and dr. sivana worked together
multiple times in the comics so it seems
like this post credit scene could be
setting up the monster Society of evil
mr. mind also talks about the seven
magic realms these are known as the
magic lions in the comics that are
currently being written by Geoff Johns
and these magic lands are at the
Darklands
the game lands of fun lands the earth
lands the monster lands that was under
lands and the wild lands and the comics
have actually only explored two of them
so far so the main thing that you need
to know about this post credits scene is
that dr. sivana and mister
mine will be teaming up moving forward
in the Shazam films and the second
post-credit scene is just for laughs
kind of poking fun at Aquaman Shazam is
trying to talk to fish and says that he
can't what good could it be for anyways
and Freddy wearing an Aquaman shirt says
I don't know maybe commanding an army of
billions so again just sort of making
fun of Aquaman but noting that they
exist in the same universe so that's it
for my breakdown of the post-credits
scene for Shazam let me know what you
thought about the movie in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
to my channel comment down below and
like the video so you can enter my
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway and stay up
to date with everything relating to
Shazam Avengers in game everything DC
and Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
you